racing games you might be relegated to
the oh my god I'm bored and I don't want
to shoot things in the face and there's
nothing else to play so what the hell
section of a games library but hey at
least you're getting some new
development love Codemasters has
unveiled grid Autosport which is coming
to the PC PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360
there's June now I know what you're
thinking hey what about this awesome new
console I just spent my girlfriend's
engagement ring money on I'm lonely and
single now where's my next-gen grid
Autosport good question
well Codemasters community manager ben
walk has some answers for you although
sadly not any solution to your newfound
singledom regarding next-gen ultimately
it comes down to a few things the first
is that we genuinely want our first
next-gen outing to be something really
great we don't want to have to rush and
only put out a handful of tracks we've
got 22 locations in Autosports the bulk
of those of real-world circuits would
all of those have made it if we were to
support next-gen thankfull secondly
we're working on our tech for next gen
now as such we're not quite ready again
we don't want to rush thirdly after grid
2 we sort of had something to prove we
wanted to leave the old gen with a bit
of a bang so to speak grid Autosport is
described as an authentic racing game by
Codemasters although that doesn't mean
it's a simulation in a lengthy
announcement on codemasters website Wolk
touched on the mechanics for grid
Autosport it's definitely not a full
simulation and he noted that it should
feel authentic not clinical grid
Autosport will include 5 disciplines and
each has their own unique style and
feeling on top of this every discipline
has a number of dedicated series within
them so that you don't just get five
broad experiences but also different
racing experiences within those styles
so there you have it folks a brand new
way of driving around in endless circles
has arrived but are you sad it's not
coming to next-gen let us know in the
comments below and for all the latest
gaming news keep it GameSpot